You read it all the time in magazines and
online, but it is true when they say actors
are just like us.
They order coffee, they go on walks, visit
the dentist and most importantly, they love
Disney movies as much as we do!
Or maybe even more.
These actors may play serious Hollywood roles,
but their hearts are filled with pure Disney
magic.
Check out these 10 actors who love Disney
movies more than you do!
Chris Evans
Who would have guessed that the man who plays
Captain America in the MCU is also a major
Disney fan?
Well, the secret was revealed when the cast
of “Captain America: Civil War” stopped
by “Jimmy Kimmel Live!” to promote the
film.
The cast was asked to guess what Disney movie
Evans had memorized all the songs lyrics to.
While the correct answer was “The Little
Mermaid,” Evan’s love of Disney didn’t
stop with just that one film.
He admitted that there were at least 5 other
Disney movies that would have fit as the correct
answer.
Tom Hiddleston
Another MCU vet, Tom Hiddleston, is known
for his epic roles in “Thor” and “The
Avengers.”
But the Hollywood superstar has revealed he
is also quite the Disney fanatic.
At the D23 expo in 2013, Hiddleston joined
costar Christina Hendricks to talk about their
film “The Pirate Fairy.”
However, fans wanted Hiddleston to prove his
Disney knowledge with a solo of “The Jungle
Book” song “Bare Necessities.”
And, without any hesitation, the 32-year-old
English actor busted out into song as the
crowd cheered him on.
He later revealed he once sang that song at
an audition and has always been a huge Disney
fan.
Julie Andrews
It shouldn’t come as a surprise that the
actress famous for portraying Mary Poppins
in the 1964 film has a fondness for Disney.
Well, to be more accurate, the actress has
a soft spot for the Disney songbook.
In fact, she has an entire album dedicated
to her favorite Disney tracks.
The album includes songs like: “Part of
Your World” from “The Little Mermaid,”
The Bare Necessities” from “The Jungle
Book” and “A Whole New World” from “Aladdin.”
Lana Parrilla
It’s not too hard to believe that the Evil
Queen from ABC’s fairytale drama is a Disney
fan.
However, it is a surprise who she relates
to the most.
Lana Parrilla revealed she adored Ariel as
a child, but found as she got older Ursula
was more fascinating to watch.
She even mentions that the evil sea witch
had some help in developing the character
of the Evil Queen in “Once Upon a Time.”
Jennifer Morrison
Another “OUAT” actor, Jennifer Morrison
has also admitted that she too is a big Disney
fan.
In an interview with Hypable, Morrison reveals
her favorite characters are Cinderella and
Alice.
She explains the latter by saying, “I was
a very misunderstood kid.
I was a little slow to develop socially.
I did well academically but my social skills
kicked in later in life.
I was an outsider, so I identified with her
sense of being an outsider.”
Kristen Bell
Kristen Bell, who voiced a character in one
of Disney’s biggest films, is fittingly
a big Disney fan.
Before landing the role of Anna in “Frozen,”
Bell told Huffington Post, “It had always
been on my bucket list to be in a Disney musical.”
She also revealed that her favorite Disney
classic lies between “The Little Mermaid”
and “Aladdin” as one of them is always
on a loop in her house at all times.
Idina Menzel
The other star of “Frozen,”, Idina Menzel,
has revealed that she has a lot of Disney
movies in her favorite list.
But only one holds a special place in her
heart.
In an interview with Digital Spy, Menzel,
who plays the Ice Queen in “Frozen,” revealed
“Lady and the Tramp” was her all time
favorite Disney film.
It holds a special place for her because it
was the first movie her grandfather ever took
her to see.
Josh Hutcherson
“The Hunger Games” heartthrob Josh Hutcherson
is absolutely in love with the Disney film
“The Lion King.”
After naming the movie as one of his top favorites
in more than one list, he gave a bit more
detail.
The 24-year-old actor revealed “The Lion
King” was a staple of his childhood.
And he even admitted he went to watch it in
theaters again when it re-released in 2012.
Hutcherson said, for him, the movie held so
many morals that had been part of his life
since he was younger.
While it’s great he can carry life lessons
from the film, we can’t help but picture
a young Hutcherson singing “I Can’t Wait
To Be King” at the top of his lungs.
Terrence Howard
It’s hard to believe that Terrence Howard
holds a Disney classic like “Mary Poppins”
as one of his all-time favorite films, but
he indeed does.
According to Howard, the film has so many
wonderful jewels of knowledge.
He also found some life lessons in the film,
like how to be successful in life and learning
that a person’s greatest success is to be
happy.
It’s incredible that this film can still
show him aspects about life.
But we just want to watch this movie with
him and have a sing-along.
Jeremy Renner
When Jeremy Renner isn’t busy starring as
the superhero archer Hawkeye in “The Avengers”
films, he is probably thinking about his favorite
Disney movie—“The Jungle Book.”
When asked who his favorite “Jungle Book”
character was, Renner said: “OOOH!
You can't have a favorite character in the
Jungle Book, they're all amazing! Shere Khan
is amazing - Baloo is probably the closest
- I think Khan has the best voice, but Baloo
is the best character.
Classic Disney film.”
What do you think of our list?
What other actors are not-so-secretly obsessed
with Disney movies?
Join the discussion in the comments below,
and subscribe to our YouTube channel for more
videos like this one.